SATYAJEET SALGAR: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming here
and watching online.
My name is Satyajeet Salgar.
I'm here with Ibrahim.
And we're here to talk about the
YouTube Live platform and
the YouTube Live APIs.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about the platform, what
creators are doing.
Ibrahim is going to dive into
details of the API and show
you a demo.
And we'll save some time at
the end for questions.
Does that sound good?
We're also going to take
questions from the live
streaming audience on the Google
Moderator link that you
see online.
So we look forward to
your questions.
All right.
This is a live streaming talk
with a live streaming demo
that will be live streamed,
but we can go deeper if
someone live streams us.
So it is possible.
YouTube.
How many people watched
a YouTube
video in the last month?
You are part of 1 billion
people, which is about half
the people that are on the
internet right now.
They watch 6 billion hours
every month, and
really across platforms.
So 25% of our views globally
are on mobile devices.
YouTube is also the largest
search engine in the world.
So clearly, we believe YouTube
and video is a great tool to
build engagement and
create great
experiences for your audience.
We think live, particularly
so.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about Live on YouTube.
How many people recognize
this image?
Almost everyone.
So for those of you who don't,
on the 14th of October, an
Austrian gentleman by the name
of Felix Baumgartner got into
that space capsule, went up 24
miles into space, looked down
over New Mexico, and
then jumped.
The jump was about 10 minutes,
and he was in free fall for
about four minutes.
This is what we saw internet
traffic looking like during
that period.
Yeah.
A couple of people, like me,
stayed for the press
conference.
But this was the peak.
And at its peak, 8.2 million
people tuned in.
And there are 52 million
playbacks.
That is the kind of scale and
excitement that a live event
on YouTube can generate.
By the way, fun piece of trivia,
at that point-- those
four minutes-- about
8% of all internet
traffic was that video.
Fortunately, you don't have to
jump from space to create
great live entertainment.
And we're seeing tons and
tons of partners do
that today on YouTube.
Up on the top left over there,
whenever soccer powerhouse
Spartak Moscow plays in Russia,
we see live traffic
from Russia spike.
Live sports is a great way
to build entertainment on
YouTube, whether it's cricket
in India or major league
baseball that live streams its
games internationally, or the
NBA developmental league.
Or it's really sports that
anyone looks for that are hard
to find anywhere in the world.
For example, surfing from
Australia, boys high school
soccer, or badminton in
Indonesia, local hockey in
India-- all of these
experiences are live on YouTube.
And audiences are finding
these, and channels are
building their audiences
on YouTube.
But our vision for sports
isn't just the game.
We think there's tons of live
stuff around the game, whether
it's the tunnel cam as you're
walking into the auditorium,
whether it's the interview
afterwards.
These are all part of the
live sports experience.
How many people know
who Juventus is?
Not that many people-- all
right, a couple of people.
So Juventus is a soccer
club in Italy.
They just won the league.
That is a live stream that the
club put together when the
entire town celebrated
their win.
Tens of thousands of people
tuned in, and it was a way for
their global fans to participate
in that.
We see this happening in tons
and tons of dimensions.
Music is another great one,
whether it's the Ultra Music
Festival in Miami, or Coachella,
or AKB48 in Japan,
or that gentleman, PSY, who
debuted his new album in a
live stream on YouTube.
We're seeing artists of all the
sorts come to YouTube and
create great live experiences
for their audience.
And we think this is
just the beginning.
We think this is going to
extend to all sorts of
independent artists.
And I say artists to mean much
more than just musicians.
Of course, we think gaming is
going to be a huge part of
Live on YouTube.
We're starting to see this
already with lots of major
e-sports tournaments coming
out of the platform.
Ride Games, for example, streams
its League of Legends
tournaments.
We're seeing tons more.
We recently did an API
integration with Call of Duty,
Black Ops II, which actually
allows you to live stream your
multiplayer gameplay.
Now, we all understand the
value of watching someone
who's really good play, right?
But it extends to
more than that.
For example, a few weeks ago,
I was clicking through the
Call of Duty shelf,
and I happened to
stumble on someone playing.
And it became pretty clear
within a couple of seconds
that this person actually
wasn't very good.
But suddenly, she paused and
actually started chatting with
the audience saying,
hey, thank you
for watching me play.
I know I'm not that great, but
I'm getting a lot better.
And this is what
I did recently.
Now, the act of two or three of
us that were watching her
made her experience better.
It became more than just
a game for her.
That is the power of live
streaming and connecting with
an audience that we're seeing
every day on YouTube.
And it extends to entertainment
of all sorts,
whether it's product launches,
or conferences exactly like
this, or very elaborate
April Fools pranks.
Do people recognize the YouTube
April Fools prank in
the top right?
A few people?
Yeah, this was a live stream
that went on for 12 hours
where these very brave anchors
actually read the titles and
descriptions of basically
hundreds of thousands of
YouTube videos.
Or something like red
carpet premieres.
What can we do that's better?
Check out the multi-cam
on top.
You can't do this
anywhere else.
So we weren't just streaming
one particular view.
But we were letting audiences
select where
they wanted to go.
We can do this across genres.
For example, recently
the PGA live
streamed just Tiger Woods.
So if you wanted to follow
just Tiger Woods during a
tournament, you could
actually do that.
And of course, this extends
to much, much more.
It also goes to news
and current events.
We had the pope on YouTube.
We had the presidential debate
on YouTube, and not just the
US presidential debate.
What you see here on the top
right is the first ever
presidential debate in Kenya.
And we had a huge traffic spike
in Kenya, and we were
wondering what it is.
And it turned out to
be this event.
Tons of international
news channels
broadcast live on YouTube.
And of course, we have a lot
of topical coverage.
Now, we're really excited by
everything that our creator
community is doing on YouTube.
But what makes this possible?
What we're really excited about
is the powerful solution
that we've built.
The YouTube engineering team has
worked hard over the last
couple of years to
build a solution
that I feel is amazing.
As a viewer, we offer you
unmatched stream quality.
We offer things like
adaptive bit rate.
So as you move around and your
bandwidth changes, we figure
that out, and you don't suffer
a loss in stream quality.
We let you skip back and
forth in the stream.
And we work across devices.
So whether you go from
your desktop or your
phone, it just works.
Unmatched scale and quality.
As a creator, we offer you the
ability to easily insert ads,
to send us just one high quality
stream and we do all
the transcoding in real time for
you in the cloud, and to
all the necessary devices
and resolutions.
We offer you multiple
camera angles.
We let you insert ads.
We let you do slates.
We make it really easy to
insert closed captions.
There's a lot more, and we're
just getting started.
We're going to continue to build
out this platform and
make it more valuable to our
creator community and to
developers.
We released a Live API which
lets partners and developers
build incredible things.
Thank you to all the beta
partners-- many of
you are in the room--
for helping us grow this API.
And we're excited to see what
more you do with this.
Finally, what we're really
excited about is the fact that
we're making this platform more
accessible to creators.
Yesterday, we announced that
anyone on YouTube with over
1,000 subscribers can
now stream live.
We think this will make this
platform even more valuable to
develop for.
And we're really excited about
both what the creator
community can do as well is how
you can take advantage of
this as developers.
With that, Ibrahim do you want
to tell them about the API?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sure.
So I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya,
developer
programs engineer at YouTube.
Today, I will actually give an
overview of the API itself.
Then I will try to suggest
the settings
for the live streaming.
And we'll go over a little bit
on the Java sample code.
At the end, we will see an
Android demo actually.
We will see it live since
we are talking live.
So let's get it started.
YouTube live streaming API.
With the live streaming API,
you can actually schedule
updates and manage your live
events on YouTube.
You can instantiate your own
streams and make them happen
inside these events.
If you're a YouTube content
partner, you can also insert
advertisements.
I want to talk right now a
little bit about the concepts.
The first concept I want to talk
today is the broadcast.
Think about the broadcast
as a calendar event like
a show, like news.
They're scheduled for
some time, and it's
like an event container.
And when you go to YouTube/live,
you will see
this image.
You will see the events that are
either happening right now
or they are scheduled for
some future time.
The second concept
is a stream.
A stream is what we are
sending to YouTube.
It is your entry point
to those events.
So I want to differentiate
those two.
The broadcast is the event--
the event that was scheduled
for some specific time.
And the stream is your
own content, the
entry point to YouTube.
So this actually covers those,
broadcast was the event, the
event metadata, and the
stream was the live
streaming your content.
The reason we separated
together, we want you to have
flexibility so that you can
have multiple streams.
You can't switch in and out
those streams for the
broadcast event itself.
And if you are maybe having your
own streams, and you use
that stream, you may want to
use the same stream, same
ingestion settings,
to another event.
So we make it flexible that
we separated those two.
And last but not least,
the cuepoint.
Cuepoint is in-stream ads.
They are built on
the partner API.
If you are a YouTube content
partner, you'll be also able
to insert advertisement.
So how do they play
with each other?
As I said, the broadcast
is the event.
And when you want
your stream--
your content to appear in the
event, you are just binding
them together.
And when you want to insert
an advertisement, you are
inserting the advertisement
to the event.
When you combine this stream to
the broadcast, your stream
happens to be in
this broadcast.
It streams inside this event.
When you want another stream,
you can't connect them.
There's always one-to-one
mapping.
Right, now I want to deep
dive on these concepts.
So the broadcast is a metadata,
as I explained.
It has a title, description,
scheduled time.
You can make it a private
or a public event.
With the new platform, you can
actually enable recording.
So if the users didn't see your
live stream, they may go
to YouTube and still see
the video later on.
And you can enable them to use
DVR settings such that they
can go back and forth
inside the video.
This was scheduling the event.
And what about managing
the event live cycle?
So when you first created
the event, you start
as a creative slate.
And when you bind them together
and it's ready to
start, we are in the
ready state.
So users see that your event
will start soon.
And as an optional state,
you can go to preview.
So this is a really good state
that actually before your
event goes to live, you can
monitor your stream.
We send you another monitor URL
that you can go there and
you can see your stream
before it goes public.
And when you are ready
to go, magic happens.
It goes street live.
And every good thing needs to
end at some point, so when you
want to complete this, you just
go to complete cycle.
What about the stream?
Stream was your entry point.
It is where your streamer
talks to YouTube.
So you create this
entry point.
You set a name for yourself
so you can remember.
And then you set the highest
bitrate you want to support.
You set the highest resolution
you want to support.
And one thing really important
about the stream is that entry
point, once you create this,
you are actually getting a
RTMP URL and stream name so
that you know where is the
point you will talk
to access these
streams, send your streamer.
And the latest one
is the cuepoint.
As I explained, it was
the in-stream ad.
So you're setting the in-stream
ad to start and how
long it will be.
Let's remember how
they interact
with each other again.
And your stream is bound to
the broadcast so that your
stream happens to be
in this event.
And once you want to insert
advertisements if you're a
content partner, you are
using the insert.
So how many people used
live streaming
before in any channel?
OK, I see a few.
And how many people use encoding
and decoding, maybe
not in live streaming?
OK.
I see a few more.
And maybe you are wondering
right now-- you saw these
concepts and the API, but what
about the best live streaming
settings for YouTube?
So right now, with this amazing
new platform, we are
supporting all the standard
bitrates, all the standard
resolutions from 240p
up to 1080p.
And a great feature about this
product is you don't need to
send all these different
bitrates, all these different
resolutions to YouTube.
You just want to send us the
highest bitrate you want to
support, the highest
resolution you want to support.
And from there, in real time,
we will transcode it to all
lower qualities.
So you are saving
the bandwidth.
You are saving the
processing power.
And we'll do the whole heavy
lifting for you.
What about the encoder?
Currently, we are supporting
the RTMP flash streaming.
And you want to use
the H.264 video.
And for older codecs, we
are supporting the AAC.
Similar to what I explained
earlier, as we transcode to
lower bitrates, we also
transcode to different
containers and different
qualities so that people
coming from iOS, Android, and
Google TV can also see your
stream as well.
So you don't need to think about
how you will change your
stream into those different
settings.
We will do this for you.
So this was the first streaming
settings and the API overview.
And as you may actually have--
I know there are developers in
this platform, and I want to
talk about with our
other sample.
All the samples I will be
talking today, they are open
sourced under the YouTube
API samples.
So if you are missing
one thing or
two, don't be excited.
They are all open sourced.
You can go there and
still access them.
And today I will be talking
about just the Java sample,
but we support all client
libraries from Python to
PHP.net to Objective-C,
many of them.
And you can see what other
client libraries we support.
And it's a totally
RESTful API.
Even though if you don't want to
use the client library, you
can just use the REST API.
So the first example I
want to go through
is the create broadcast.
Today, I want to do
three things.
I want to start creating a
broadcast, then create the
stream and connect
them together.
So I will have something that
is ready to live stream.
Create broadcast is I will
start with setting the
metadata, and then I will
set the status.
And using those two, I will
create a broadcast object.
And now I want to create this
broadcast object in YouTube.
So I will create an Insert
request and execute it.
So I will start with
the broadcast
snippet, the metadata.
I set it, and I created
the title.
I set my scheduled time.
And one thing to remember, I'm
setting today just the
required parameters.
There are other parameters I
explained earlier, but I'm
just doing the minimal
right now.
And the second was the status.
With the status, for
the sake of this
example, I set it to private.
Using the previous, I set the
snippet and the status, I'm
creating a broadcast object.
Now I want to insert this
broadcast object to YouTube so
it will appear in YouTube too.
So I create that
insert request.
And using the client library,
I have the live broadcast
insert request, insert class.
And I wrap my broadcast
object I created
earlier inside this request.
And I executed it.
And I explained, it
was a RESTful API.
If everything got successfully
by the client library, the
JSON is passed, and I got the
return broadcast, which the
broadcast actually was inserted
inside YouTube.
So from then on, I can check
like everything I did was
successful or not.
So after you create the
broadcast, the second step was
the stream.
The stream will be--
I will do a similar tree.
I will start with
the metadata.
I will set my ingestion
settings.
And I will create the
stream object.
At the end, I will insert
it into YouTube.
So I start with the snippet.
I will set the title since
this was the metadata.
Then I will go over the
ingestion settings.
In the ingestion settings,
as I explained, we
support right now RTMP.
And just for the sake of this
example, I set it at 1080p.
So this one is the maximum
resolution I want to support.
I will create the stream object
right now and set the
snippet and the ingestion
settings I just created.
Now is the time to insert
it into YouTube.
So I create the insert
object again.
This time it's the live
stream insert object.
And I put my stream inside it.
Once I executed it, I return
that the created stream is
from YouTube.
Something to remember.
As I explained earlier, this
is your entry point to
YouTube, your stream's
entry point.
So once you create this stream,
you are actually
getting an ingestion address,
the RTMP URL
and the stream name.
So using the same API, we are
actually resolving them-- the
ingestion address, the stream
name, so we know where to
steam, where to send
our streamer to.
So we create the
stream as well.
So far, we created the event,
we created the stream.
Something is missing.
I think it's the connection.
So we want to let the stream
happen inside this event.
So we will create
a bind request.
We will set the broadcast
ID inside it.
We will set the set stream ID.
Once we execute it, if it's
successful, we will return the
broadcast as well.
Now we can check if the binding
is successful or not.
So this was a java sample, but
I want to run it on my
computer so we see that it
will be going to YouTube.
So I'm using the same example
I just showed, the create
broadcast example.
I will run it.
And I'm using the OAuth 2.0
method so that it will do this
creating stream, this example,
create the stream on my
account, on my behalf.
So I will allow access.
And once I allow access, I
will start using my demo.
So just for the stream broadcast
event titled "I/O
'13
Event." OK.
So I see that the event
is created.
It's just published.
I will create an
actual stream.
So I just create the
stream as well.
As I explained earlier, once you
create the stream, I see
that I have an ingestion
address.
And I have my stream name--
my unique stream name.
So using those two, I know where
to stream my data into.
And last thing, as I explained,
now I bind them together.
So the broadcast ID I created
and stream ID I created, I
bind them together
so my event knows
which stream to broadcast.
Let's go one level down and
go to YouTube website.
I am in my account as my account
is enabled for live.
So I can see that I have
live events here.
The event I just created, "I/O
'13 Event." And let's click on
this event.
And I see that it's private,
as I explained.
It's scheduled ahead of time.
I will go to ingestion
settings.
And I see that the event I
just created, "I/O Stream
Event," is here.
And it is 1080p as
I just described.
So this was a demo for Java.
And I really want to go
one level further.
And I created a small streaming
app that I will try
to stream from here.
Let's see.
So first I will start the--
let me turn this.
OK.
So first I will start
with sign in.
I use the Google Play
account manager.
So from there, my
account is here.
I will just pick my account.
And now I will authorize
the event.
And I will create my event.
So right now what's happening
is I created the event, I
created my unique steam, and
then I connect them together.
And as I went to the live
events, I just list them.
And as you see, the one I just
created before, the "I/O '13"
is over there.
The one I just created right
now, it is a live streaming
event here.
So I'm seeing this.
And I will start streaming
right now.
And so it looks like I
started streaming.
So let's see on the
YouTube website.
And my live stream event.
I will actually go to live
streaming to see what's
happening here right now.
Yeah.
My streaming started
happening here.
And from my API, I already
clicked to start streaming
from the API.
So I didn't have to click,
because it was already--
I requested to start
the stream.
And right now, our servers
are transcoding it.
And in just a few seconds,
we'll go live.
So let's see it.
I'll go back to my account,
to my event.
This time I will just click.
And my event is about
to start.
Just give it a few seconds.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Give it
a couple of seconds.
It looks like the demo gods
are being favorable today.
Can we blame the network?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sorry?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Can we
blame the network?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah,
sure, why not?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Why not?
All right.
Give us a couple of seconds.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: No.
The question was, if I was
streaming to I/O '13 or to
this event.
Actually, as I just did here,
I actually seem to do a live
streaming event.
I/O '13 was the one I used
from my Java Eclipse.
So today I showed the Eclipse.
But you are free to use the
language of your choice as
well as-- something
is happening.
And yeah, we are live.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yeah,
there we go.
[APPLAUSE]
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We should
get the audience on.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I didn't
want to send audio.
So that was all about
my demo today.
I just wanted you to see that it
was that easy to create the
live event and go live.
And from now on, we can start
taking questions.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We're happy
to take questions.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: If you have a
question, fee free to go to a
microphone.
And we'll take live questions
as well as we will take
questions from the
moderator link.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: The only
question on the moderator link
is, "why is Ibrahim
so awesome?" And I
think I asked that.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: So it's
all very nice.
On iOS, you are presumably using
HLS as the protocol--
HTTP live streaming,
right, on iOS?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yes.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: We
are using RTMP.
AUDIENCE: Now, on Android, the
Android has had a much more
tortured history of
the implementation
of multimedia protocols.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: I'm sorry.
I missed what you said
there a little bit.
AUDIENCE: On Android.
On Android, are you also using
HLS, which is supported by the
Chrome browser it appears, or
are you using a different
protocol to stream
live to Android?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: The question
was if we are using HLS or
another protocol.
AUDIENCE: On Android.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: With Android,
we are actually using
the RTMP right now.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Are you
talking about playback or the
streamer from the
creator side?
AUDIENCE: Playback.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Playback.
Playback, HLS.
AUDIENCE: HLS on Android?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: I believe so.
Jarek?
Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I think it's just until the
version of Android.
So we do transcode
[INAUDIBLE].
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sorry.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Oh, sorry.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One key
feature of this platform is it
transcodes to a number
of different formats.
[INAUDIBLE].
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yeah,
come on up.
Oh, by the way, the answer, for
most people that didn't
hear it, was we transcode to a
number of different formats.
On most versions of Android, it
is HLS, on the later ones.
On some, it's something
different.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the API open to
anyone or just open to some
organizations?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: The API
is open to everyone.
AUDIENCE: Anyone?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: It's
public, and it's--
yeah, it's public, and
it's open right now.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if I create a mobile app to
anyone so they had to log into
their account to allow
them [INAUDIBLE]?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yeah,
so anyone can develop
using the Live API.
The constraint we have right now
is you need at least 1,000
subscribers before you can
stream into your account.
That's something we're
working on.
We're working on expanding
live access.
But the constraint right now
is the person whose account
you're streaming to needs to
have a certain number of
subscribers and be in good
standing as a YouTube account.
AUDIENCE: OK, then that's
also my next question.
What's the limitation to
use the API, then?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the limitation
to use the API?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Anyone
can use the API.
So if you're developing tools
to live stream to YouTube.
The API is public.
There's no-- other than
the developer key.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: No, the API is
all public as well as the
documentation.
The only thing that we are
constrained about is the
channel that you will
be live streaming.
So if you have a test channel,
or if you use one channel to
use the API, you can
always use the API.
But once you start
live steaming--
At the end, when you develop
your product and your product
is ready, the people who will
use the product will need a
channel that they will actually
send their live
streams into.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
They need a channel.
But how do you screen the
content of the live stream?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So how
do we manage content?
AUDIENCE: For example, if you
stream something that should
not be public, how do
you detect that?
How do you prevent it?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Aha, you're
worried about spam.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So we have--
this is something that we've
invested a lot of time and
effort in at YouTube.
So all the mechanisms that
protect content on YouTube in
general for video also apply
to live streams.
So people can flag the stream,
and it goes down.
We have a tool called content
ID, which screens for
infringing content.
That's run against live
streams as well.
Anything else?
All right.
It's a shy audience.
Thank you very much for
listening to our talk.
Thank you for listening
online.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Thanks,
everyone.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Ibrahim and
I are hanging out here.
Feel free to come up
and ask questions.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: If you have any
other questions, we will
be in the sandbox area all
day, as well as the other
YouTube experts.
So you can always come and ask
other questions there.
We will follow up
on everything.
Thanks.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Thank you.